Dwight, Billy Bob,
congratulations.
You made it to the final
round of this competition.
Now we're sending you back to
your home forges for five days
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history,
and that weapon
is the rhomphaia.
Originating as early as
400 BC, the rhomphaia
was a fearsome weapon
prominently used
by Thracian tribes
of eastern Europe.
It featured a long single-edged
blade that had great
cutting and slashing
strength due to the blade's
slightly forward curve.
Usually forged
with iron, warriors
had to use two hands to
wield this heavy weapon using
an overhead sweeping
or hacking motion
to attack from close distances.
First mentioned
in historical text
by the ancient Roman
historian Titus Livius.
It was recorded as
one of the key weapons
in violent Thracian warfare.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
My name is Dwight Phillips,
and I was the first person
from Tennessee
that I know of that
passed the master-smith test.
What I love about bladesmithing,
200 years from now,
somebody else is
going to be picking
it up and looking at it.
That really satisfies me.
It looks pretty good.
The thing I'm worried
about is the handle.
I went with a full tang, which
makes it a little bit heavier.
I may have to drill
some holes in there
and take away some weight.
That made me a little nervous.
Next, we will clay it and
get ready for heat treat.
This will help keep
part of the metal soft,
and the other part
will get hard.
I feel really nervous about
quenching something this long,
but what the heck?
Let's go see what happens.
If this heat treat goes wrong,
I could be in serious trouble.
The time it takes to work
out another sword this long,
I'll be down and out.
I'm more nervous
than a mouse that's
running from a cat on this.
With no cracks in the
edge, and it wouldn't warp.
It looks perfect.
Let's check it out here.
It's dragging right there.
Kind of running out of time.
If I don't get this
blade razor sharp,
Billy Bob could
take home the money.
I have got to fix it.
That's better.
If I had a lot more time, I
could really stone this edge
and get it even
sharper than that.
But I think it's going
to go through everything
they put up against it.
We just had to see.
My name is Bill Saule.
Everybody in the knife
world calls me Billy Bob.
I've been a master-smith
for eight years.
When I decided to make a
knife, I'm just going to do it,
and there's not a
lot of planing to it.
You just keep doing
it until it's a knife.
The sword isn't fitting all
the way through the forge,
so I just made one renovation.
I just knocked a
hole in the firewall.
So I think I'm going to
make a simple pattern
of twisted Damascus, and
I can put it on the handle
and give it a little detail.
Oh.
Never pick a snowball
up in a blacksmith shop
because it could be hot.
I'm way behind.
This is no bull [bleep].
The handle is harder
than I expected.
Today, I'm going to try to
fit and shape the handle.
Oh, yes, baby.
I'm doing it in two pieces.
It just adds to
the craftsmanship.
Son of a bitch.
The handle is looking a lot
better than I thought it would,
but we're never out of the woods
until we send this bad boy off.
[bleep] damn it.
The [bleep] treads are crooked.
Being a perfectionist, I'm
going to keep messing with it
till I get it right.
That may be the downfall
of this whole thing.
Master bladesmiths, to see
what kind of lethal damage
your rhomphaias, we'll
take your rhomphaias
and deliver lethal
slashes and thrusts
on this wild boar carcass.
Dwight, you're up first.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
As you can see, I'm still
recovering from an injury,
so to be my arm today,
I'd like to welcome
my brother, RJ Marcaida.
[music playing]
Wow.
Well, Dwight, on
the initial draw cut,
it is sharp to where
it lacerated deep
into this wild boar carcass.
On the thrust, it penetrated
easily into the carcass,
and on the final cut right
here, your blade cut all
the way through the carcass.
Overall, your
rhomphaia will kill.
Thank you.
DOUG: Good job.
All right, Billy Bob.
That's a hard act to
follow, but let's do it.
[music playing]
All right, Billy Bob.
It's so light you can almost
wield it with one hand.
The edge over here is
so sharp it lacerates
easily without much force.
The profile you have
over here for thrusting
allowed it for a very deep,
quick in-out penetration.
Overall, your
rhomphaia will kill.
Thank you.
Next up is the strength test.
Tim.
Gentlemen, to test the
strength and durability
of your blades, I'm going to
clamp them into this machine,
and it will deliver a
strike on the sugar cane
of about 500 pounds of force.
Remember, this test is all
about what the sugar cane
does to your blade and
not what your blade
does to the sugar cane.
Dwight, I've already
clamped yours in.
Are you ready to go?
I'm ready.
3, 2, 1.
Well, Dwight, your
blade held up perfectly.
It's like it didn't
hit anything.
It's still dead straight.
Very well done.
Thank you.
Billy Bob, you're up next.
You ready?
I can't wait.
All right.
Let's do this.
3, 2, 1.
Ah, you killed me.
Well, Billy Bob, I
love the overall weight.
It feels like it's a really good
chopper, and, most importantly,
the edge is still
as razor sharp as it
was when you brought it here.
Very well done.
Thank you, sir.
Next up is the sharpness
test, and for that,
I give you to Dave.
All right, gentlemen,
I'll be working
my way through this
rope maze by cutting.
We've seen your blades kill.
Let's see if they've
held their edge.
Dwight, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
All right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, so, Dwight, your
blade is just pristine.
I mean, there's not a mark or a
hair hanging on it or anything.
Feel-wise, it's got a
lot of forward weight.
Makes for a very strong chop,
but I do have to stop it,
slow it down, and back it up.
I think it's a beautiful weapon.
Thank you.
All right, Billy Bob.
You ready to go?
Let's do it.
DAVE: OK.
[music playing]
Billy Bob, this is sharp.
It blew through
rope like nothing.
I felt I could really
control this weapon
just because it's so much
lighter up through here.
Fabulous weapon.
Thank you.
Well done.
Dwight, Billy Bob,
both done masterful work
as expected from master-smiths.
However, in this
arena of competition,
there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion,
and that champion is Billy Bob.
Congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Thank you.
Dwight, your blade was
bad-ass, but this time,
it didn't make the cut.
Doug Marcaida will explain.
Dwight, first of
all, this is exactly
what we expect
for a final round,
two beautifully-matched blades.
But your blade is
slightly heavy.
That offsets its
balance compared
to Billy Bob's, and for that
reason we're sending you home.
Dwight, I need to ask you to
please surrender your blade.
Billy Bob winning
is no disgrace.
I believe both blades
are pretty equal.
I'd hate to have been a judge.
Being on "Forged in
Fire" is one of the best
experiences I've ever had.
If it's something that
you're passionate about,
you need to go for it.
Billy Bob, congratulations.
You are the new "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
Thank you.
I'm honored to have
been here to do it.
Please present your
weapon to the judges.
The old man won
"Forged in Fire."
The old man come here and
kicked ass and took names.
It feels good, man.
I'm proud of both of us.
Dwight and I forged
not only blades,
but we forged a friendship.
I'm going to go home
and take a break.
I'm going to get
me a damn pedicure.
You don't know what you're
missing if you ain't had one.